challenger Owen Smith joins me now in a
very good morning to you mr. mourneth
well let's talk about the the polling I
mean it's looking pretty grim for you it
must be said well there's only be one
poll so far do people keep talking about
the polls it was one poll done by
populous and you go rather and the
Early's vote this being so far was in
the GM bees membership and there I won
26,000 to 17,000 so I don't know what
the results gonna be I'm just gonna keep
on going talking about the issues to the
end but and I've heard some of your
supporters talking about you know the
unexpected brexit result after the polls
the general election before that but
those polls is turns out we're only two
or three percentage points out that poll
you're talking about has Jeremy Corbyn
on 62% it have to be 13 14 points out
it's pretty unlikely yeah look and Janet
Amelia has always been the favor in this
to him we know that he was he won with
60% last time I was obviously always the
underdog in this fight but I hope I've
spoken with passion about what I believe
I said very clearly that I think the
party isn't going to win an election
with Jeremy as leader and I said very
clearly if I don't think we've been a
very strong opposition with him I don't
think we've been united and I do think
we need to change the leader of the
Labour Party in order to get back to
being a something the country can look
at and see is a credible alternative to
the Tories so this is a part of you now
you wake up in the middle of the night
thing this could really have backfired
he was of course destabilized by all
those resignations by the the lack of a
vote of confidence in him by the
parliamentary Labour Party and you've
given him a chance here how many if he
wins this with an even bigger majority
you've given mr. Corbin a chance those
of you that want to see him out of
strengthening his grip on labour
potentially yes I mean I didn't start
this fight as it were I was someone who
came to challenge once a challenge had
already been leveled at Jeremy but I
still think that we've had a really
important debate in labour whatever the
outcome of this we've been forced if you
like to look at ourselves and think much
harder than we were doing about whether
we've been effective in fighting the
Tories whether we've looked like an
alternative to them whether we're
winning back some of the trust and
respect that we lost over a long period
in the public in this country and I
think that truth is that we have lost a
lot of that
Specter will not look incredible and we
needed to have this debate and we will
need to continue to have this debate
whoever wins on Saturday but you say
potentially mr. gorban could strengthen
his grip and his supporters on the party
well let's examine some of those those
processes that we hear that term or
particularly giving the membership
control of electing the Shadow Cabinet
that used to be the perogative of MPs
who are they going to pick and also this
idea of selecting and vetoing party
policy yeah I've read the report it does
rather I'm read the report in The
Observer this morning and it's presented
as apparently being a sort of
conciliatory gesture by Jeremy it isn't
a conciliatory gesture you know it's not
simply an attempt to extend democracy in
the labour party it's an attempt to
deepen divisions between new members and
MPs it's an attempt to you know further
cement his position and to use the
membership as a means of driving a wedge
between the MPs
and his leadership if he was serious
about trying to unify the party and he
would be taking serious the notion of
going back to the traditional method
we've had of guaranteeing that there was
some balance in the shadow cabinet that
everybody felt in the party that they
had some representation which was
election through the PLP you know I'm in
favor of us having more democracy in the
labour party but I don't think Jeremy
and his team can get away with saying
this is all about an olive branch when
really and truly it's about deepening
the the divisions that he's created in
the party well you've talked a lot
you've talked just now about making the
party electable there's no point having
the the best policies in the world if
you don't get a chance to implement them
precisely do you not think the back to
what we were discussing earlier you've
given Jeremy Corbyn and his supporters
in your analysis a chance to take the
party even further away from being
elected well I see I gave a big speech
at the beginning of this week Duminy
which I talked about my concerns that
there were people within the Labour
Party who are seeking to take it over
and to take it away from the vote
coalesced around momentum yeah and we've
seen I think there's a big Dispatches
program on television on Channel four
tomorrow that simply reiterates the
point I was making there in parts of the
country in most parts of the country
a mentum are seeking in their words to
take over the party and to deselect
people talking about handing out
redundancy notices to party staff
members you know the contrast is they're
talking about spending members money on
redundancy payments to staff members I'm
talking about hiring new staff members
using that money in order to put
organizing into the key seats we need to
win the next general elections as I
pointed out in the last hustings
generally doesn't even know how many
seats we need to win to form a
government now I think that's a an
illustration of the fact that he's not
terribly serious about doing that and he
is much more happy winning arguments
within the labour party then he it's
about winning the country well there are
those within your party before mr.
Corbyn gets re-elected already talking
about a split or some kind of de-facto
split with the parliamentary party party
elements of that running itself in the
House of Commons if you lose will you be
joining those forces so would you be
considering joining mr corbyn's front
bench no I've said clearly already that
I don't think I could serve on the front
bench under Jeremy's leadership because
I don't think I could do that with
integrity having spent the summer saying
that I don't think Jeremy is up to the
job and that I don't think Jeremy's
going to lead us to victory I think it
would be wrong for me then to serve
alongside Jeremy but I won't do what
Jeremy did generally voted against the
Labour government and the Labour Party
formed from 50 odd times 500 times I
think you know I'm not gonna do that I'm
gonna carry on what about this plan I
mean who doesn't say these people
talking about a de facto split even some
even talking about a formal split I
think I think any talk of splits is
disaster for labour I think we've got to
fight to win the party respect back in
the country I think that means fighting
within the labour party making our
arguments in a comradely fashion not
trying to deepen these divisions but
being honest about where we sit right
now Jeremy used to talk about wanting a
bit more honest straight talking
politics and I agree with him about that
but he's not honest to say we're but the
thing is there we talk about honesty
given the conversations that we've had
over the last few weeks and months if
mr. gorban wins and you're sitting there
on the back benches loyally supporting
him we'll know you're living a lie you
don't you
believe it well I'll be supporting labor
because I fundamentally believe that if
you are I fundamentally believe in
loyalty in labor and whilst live
challenged Jeremy you know it's not been
because I don't want to take over the
Labor Party it's because I want to make
sure that the Labour Party the party I
love and a been in for a long long time
is electable and is speaking to the
concerns of the country that's what I've
tried to do during this contest I've
spoken about you know the need for big
investment but I've said how we paid for
it I've said that we need to be
challenging the Tories on what they're
doing to the NHS and I'm worried to read
in the newspapers this morning the john
macdonald and asked a single question in
his brief a written question since he
took over the job that's not proper
opposites you were meant to be her
Majesty's loyal opposition that means
you've got to oppose and expose the
government where they're getting things
wrong
I would not be good at even that
fundamental task a little bit bigger
task of looking like a credible
alternative the policy similarities it
said between you and mr. Corbyn I saw
someone commenting then effectively what
mr. Smith is saying is is that I've got
more charisma and a better looking than
Jeremy caught because that's the way you
think you've got to let the same policy
portfolio so what's the diff alive never
said I was better looking than Jeremy's
good he's very good looking man but what
I have done is spelled out how I pay for
these things so yes I'm saying we should
invest but I'm not doing what John
McDonnell says and says I'm gonna invest
500 billion without saying it's gonna
pay for I say let's invest 200 billion
but let's show the country how we do it
through issuing long dated government
debt I've said clearly let's make sure
we can spend 60 billion over a
parliament or the NHS that's deemed to
be left-wing to want to invest in our
public services but the difference
between me and John his I've said
precisely which taxes on the very
wealthiest in this country on the one
percent I'd raise and on corporations in
order to pay for that I've said we
should retain our Trident nuclear
missile system I said we should spend 2%
on defense big differences between me
and them DOMA and I think I've scaled
those for you in if he win we'll be
having those precise discuss look
forward again I can't well it's the
Smith good see thanks Labour leadership
contender